la réforme de l'assurance chômage c'est
quelque chose de très grave mais qui qui
constitue un tour avec la réforme des
retraites et la réforme de la sécurité
sociale puisque c'est la fin de la fin
du système de solidarité universelle
instauré par par le conseil national de
la résistance ufr est tombé je pense là
maintenant on en a marre il faut qu'on
arrive vers autre chose pas vers l'avant
mais vers autre chose
l'une est d'abord là c'est un moment clé
pour nous le 1er mai ce que c'est la
journée des travailleurs et des
travailleuses depuis très très longtemps
c'est historique
et on a vraiment besoin est on est on
met tous nos espoirs dans la convergence
des luttes
parce que l'assurance chômage ça
concerne absolument tout le monde c'est
pas une question d'internet en
intermittente